you said this was what again let the
light powder okay just give me a second
though
[Music]
positive for ketamine hydrochloride
which is the DEA controlled substance
it's illegal to transport into the U.S
it's illegal to have in the US without a
prescription
be honest I didn't even know that was
the bag
you have some medications in here you
have mixed up like Adderall that's
Cialis is everything prescribed yeah
in this one
it should be all right it should be
residue from that same thing should be
there's something in there
found another baggie of a brown
um salt-like substance so we're gonna
have to do our checks and just determine
what that substance is
all right sir just come right in here
just put your backs up on the table
and we're gonna check your body make
sure you don't have anything on it so
we're gonna do a pat down sure we're
gonna recheck your bags make sure we
didn't miss anything and then we're
gonna process this see where we're gonna
go from there all right
and patting the individual down we
located a small baggie of a white
powdery substance inside his front right
pocket
took it out asked him what it was he
immediately said oh I didn't know it was
there
so now we're gonna go and retest
everything and just to verify what we
found
first one
[Music]
ketamine hydrochloride again
ketamine it always turns out blue
we tested
[Music]
cocaine hydrochloride
third one is India me
the white powders turn out to be cocaine
hydrochloride the tan color salt-like
substance turned out to be MDMA and the
pink powder is positive for ketamine
hydrochloride I'm just going to put you
right back in here
what is going to happen is we're going
to charge you a a penalty the penalty is
five thousand dollars we can mitigate it
down to five hundred dollars this is the
one you know break you're getting if you
want to call that so pay the 500 you get
some paperwork and you'll be on your way
all right
the passenger was charged a fine he was
allowed to be released upon paying the
fine some things that led into that
where his you know his cooperation with
us the amount of substances he had on
him
just in the future make sure you know
what you're bringing in your pockets and
your bags all right
that does happen often passengers say oh
I don't know what was inside this bag
but part of our inspection is we asked
those questions is this your bag
everything inside belongs to you so
before we even opened it up they're
taking responsibility for anything that
we find inside
[Music]
thank you
[Music]